chchefs de l'opposition. Dans ce
ququ'ils feraient.
ToTout d'abord Dominique Anglad.
BoBonsoir Amanda Anglade. Vous
êêtes à Gaspé et quelle est la
memeilleure façon de votre esprt
popour freiner l'inflation alors
ququ'on sait que la banque
cecentrale ailleurs où le taux
d'd'intérêt?
- - C'est directement dans la pe
ququébécoise il faut savoir que
ququand inflation élevée le
gogouvernement des moyens de
dodonner des mesures forts ici r
exexemple aujourd'hui vous avait
acacheté une maison et que les
tataux augmentent, vous serez àa
gagauche pour payer les mots das
unune. On a des mesures pour
enenlever la tasse de bienvenue.
D'D'autres mesures, c'est 2000 $
papareil de plus de son disant.
LeLes revenus après son disant
rereste office et les coûts de
mamanière importante, donner 200
$ $ par année et n'enlève pas
opopposable aider directement, s
dédépenses sont essentielles.
EÉgalement il faut penser à des
gegens qui envoient leurs enfans
dadans les services de garde qui
cocoûte 50 $, soit 100 $ par jo,
fafait en sorte que ses services
dede garde soit à huit et 70.
CÇa vient aider les gens. Il fat
trtrouver des mesures qui soient
popour aider les gens dans le
ququotidien. Ce n'est pas un
chchèque de 500 $ à droite et un
auautre après les élections pour
acacheter le votes, qui vont
chchanger les choses. Ce qui vot
chchanger les choses c'est des
memesures structurantes.
- - Avez-vous chiffré le coût de
vovos propositions?
- - On parle de milliards de
dodollars il s'agit des gens de
soson disant et plus qui....
chchacune de ces mesures font
paparti de notre plateforme.
ElElles sont chiffrées ces
memesures. Je vous dira aussi
ququ'il faut aider les gens, le
lologement, enlever la TVQ sur s
prproduits essentiels, les
mémédicaments sans ordonnance et
çaça ça est directement québécos
etet québécoises.
- - Par exemple à Tartas de
bibienvenue mais en même temps e
sosont les municipalités qu'il
enencaisse, ça pose un problème
fifiscal parce que les revenus
fofonciers sont le seul façon de
fifinancer le projet. On les
cocompense comment?
- - Avec des transferts complets
10100 % de 230 millions de
dodollars. C'est le coût de la
memesure et essais français sont
cocompensés. L'idée c'est que
ququand le blondi qu'il l va
reremettre 500 $ dans les poches
dedes Québécois, la réalité c'et
ququ'il en a pris 700 à cause
ininflation.
IlIl y a beaucoup de moyens pour
aiaider et ce que je comprends s
c'c'est que on n'est pas en tran
d'd'agir sur les éléments qui vt
popouvoir se renouveler, qui vot
sese répéter. Et 2000 $ par anne
dede plus de 70 ans, la TVQ sur
leles produits essentiels touchs
çaça va être important.
- - Et au Nouveau-Brunswick este
- - C'est plus que temps pour
agagir. Les gens ont de la misèe
àà joindre les deux bouts. On le
sesent partout, quand vous alleà
l'l'épicerie. Tout le monde
sosouffre et c'est maintenant
ququ'il faut agir et on nous
brbrandit un chèque de 500 $ por
apaprès l'élection. Ça n'a aucun
sesens.
- - Merci Madame angla depuis
GaGaspé. Paul St-Pierre Plamond,
chchef du parti québécois. Quele
esest la meilleure façon de
frfreiner l'inflation alors que
ququand même certains se sont
crcritiques par rapport à la
hahausse des taux d'intérêt? On
n'n'a pas le choix de vivre avec
çaça. Ça ne nous appartient pas.
MaMais au niveau provincial,
ququ'est-ce qu'on peut faire?
- - Et on va voir d'autres 11 du
tataux d'intérêt. Dans ce
cocontexte, il faut aider les gs
lolorsqu'ils en ont besoin. Je
rérépète mon C qu'on ne devrait
papas monnayer de l'aide
fifinancière en échange d'un vo.
OnOn pense qu'on devrait cibler
dadavantage les ménages à risqus
d'd'une faillite, les ménages
afaffaiblis sur le plan financi.
PlPlutôt que de donner des chèqs
àà tous les électeurs.
- - 500 $ ont été donnés à 94000
QuQuébécois. À moins de personn,
mamais plus de personnes.
- - Exactement, ce qui sont plus
frfragiles face à ces hausses de
prprix. Les gens s'appauvrissent
faface à l'essence. On pense qun
nene peut pas laisser les
pépétrolières faire des profits
inindécents.
EnEn Grande-Bretagne, on taxe ls
prprofits des pétrolières pour s
rerenvoyer aux gens. On pense qe
lele 500 $ de François Legault,a
dedernière fois, il est allé das
lala poche des pétrolières. Il a
fafait que transiter quelques
ininstants dans la poche de
QuQuébécois. Il faut agir là-
dedessus. C'est inacceptable. Il
fafaut également libérer les ges
dudu pétrole en leur donnant la
popossibilité d'avoir des
trtransports collectifs de qualé
etet accès aux voitures
élélectriques. Sur le plan du
lologement, ça fait longtemps
ququ'on dit qu'il faut augmenter
l'l'offre de logement social. Il
fafaut également agir sur...
- - ça ne se fera pas demain
mamatin.
- - Malheureusement, il n'y a ps
ririen de prévu sur le budget de
lala CAQ. Il faut aussi combatte
lala spéculation immobilière, on
veveut une taxe sur les
spspéculateurs étrangers pour qe
leles logements ne soient pas
l'l'objet de spéculations mais
ququ'il soit bien utilisé pour s
gegens, même chose pour les
AiAirbnb. Là-dessus, on peut ag,
onon pourrait prendre le marché
imimmobilier un peu plus
acaccessible surtout pour les ps
jejeunes qui cherchent à faire n
prpremier achat. Et sur
l'l'épicerie, mine de rien, il a
plplusieurs secteurs dans lequel
ilil n'y a pas de concurrence
ququ'il y a des prix trop élevé.
OnOn veut pénaliser les compagns
ququi trichent et notamment dans
lele domaine de l'alimentation,l
y y a de prix fixé trop haut. Ds
leles circonstances, l'aide est
prprobablement nécessaire, maise
seserait mieux de cibler les
méménages dans le besoin mais
susurtout c'est pas acceptable a
momonnayé de l'aide à des gens i
onont besoin en échange de leur
vovote. Devrait pas tolérer ça
dadans notre société.
- - Vous pensez que vos mesures
sosont compétitives avec celle s
auautres partis d'opposition
- - je pense qu'il y a du bon ds
totout ce qui est proposé par ls
opoppositions. Ce qui est prise,
c'c'est le gouvernement de la CQ
ququi nie la crise du logement
pependant des années.
OnOn met de la pression pour que
leles pétrolières cessent de vor
leles gens comme elles le font.e
momot vol n'est pas exagéré. C't
l'l'inaction et l'utilisation ds
fofonds publics qui viennent
trtransiter quelques instants ds
lala poche des gens. Mais
l'l'appauvrissement, en général,
ququébécois, il est de beaucoup
plplus que 500 $. Ce bilan, et a
fafalloir évaluer des situationà
momoyens et longs termes et non
papas juste rédiger des chèques
coconstamment. Ce n'est pas
dudurable.
- - Le coût de vos mesures?
- - Ça va faire parti du cadre
fifinancier qu'on présentera los
dedes prochaines élections.
- - Merci beaucoup.
J'J'ai parlé à Gabriel Nadeau-
DuDubois, chef parlermentaire
dede Québec solidaire,
unun peu plus tôt.
B Bonsoir Gabriel Nadeau-Duboi.
- - Bonsoir madame Dussault.
- - Le sujet est sur toutes
leles lèvres : le coût de la vi,
l'l'inflation... critiquent
leles banques centrales,
papartout dans le monde, ma foi.
EtEt monsieur Legault nous dit :
"U"Un chèque, si on est élus,
popour la population." Qu'est-ce
quque vous proposez?
GAGABRIEL NADEAU-DUBOIS
- - Je pense que c'est un manque
dede sérieux et un manque de
vivision de la part de
FrFrançois Legault. Cette crisee
l'l'inflation, c'est la pire en
3030 ans et si elle perdure dans
lele temps, qu'est-ce que va fae
FrFrançois Legault? Envoyer des
chchèques à chaque deux, à chaqe
trtrois mois, ça ne tient pas
lala route. Ce qu'il faut,
c'c'est mettre en place des
memesures structurantes pour
aiaider les familles à passer au
trtravers. Il faut contrôler
leles prix des loyers.
IlIl faut calmer la spéculation
imimmobilière pour que les maiss
reredeviennent achetables. Il ft
auaugmenter le salaire minimum à
1818 $ de l'heure. On a aussi
prproposé de doubler le crédit
d'd'impôt à la solidarité.
CÇa, ce sont quatre propositions
ququ'on a faites, dans
leles derniers mois, à Québec
sosolidaire pour agir de manière
ststructurante, de manière péree
susur les principaux postes de
dédépenses des familles et donnr
lele plus besoin au Québec.
- - Avez vous une idée du coût e
vovos propositions? Parce que
lele 500 $ en un seul coup,
c'c'est 3 milliards $.
LeLe coût de vos propositions?
- - Chacune de ces mesures-là ot
unun coût. On pourrait,
leles décliner une après l'autr.
AuAugmenter le salaire minimum à
1818 $ de l'heure, ça ne coûte
ririen à l'État québécois.
CeCe sont même des nouveaux
rerevenus, des revenus qu'on pet
ututiliser ensuite pour aller
aiaider les très petites
enentreprises ou le secteur
agagricole qui pourraient avoire
lala difficulté à transitionner
cocomme ça vers un salaire minim
àà 18 $ dollars de l'heure.
DeDes solutions, il y en a,
mamais une chose qui n'est pas
unune solution, c'est d'envoyer
dedes chèques comme ça
pépériodiquement. Ça va coûter
trtrès cher au Trésor québécois.
EtEt pendant ce temps-là,
dedes entreprises comme
leles pétrolières, par exemple,
s's'en mettent plein les poches
avavec des profits historiques.
DoDonc, on ne peut pas se
cocontenter d'envoyer des chèqus
àà répétition. C'est une visionà
cocourt terme, à courte vue.
CÇa me fait penser un peu à
lala manière dont on gère les ns
dede poule au Québec. On patche
unun trou, ensuite le trou
réréapparaît. On repatche le tru
unune deuxième fois. On ne peut
papas affronter comme ça la pire
crcrise d'inflation qu'on a véce
auau Québec et au canada,
enen 30 ans.
- - Évidemment, le salaire
miminimum, il y a des gens qui
vovous diraient qu'on a une façn
dede calculer, et si ça pourrait
mmême nuire à l'économie.
P Par contre, les autres mesur,
c'c'est important de les chiffr.
DoDonc je reviens avec
lala question : les fameux créds
d'd'impôt pour les 60 ans et
6565 ans et plus, le crédit
sosolidarité. Même vous planchez
susur un gel du tarif
d'd'électricité. Ça, ça a été
exexclu par le gouvernement.
- - Une autre des mesures
ququ'on propose, c'est
unun moratoire sur les hausses e
loloyer, un gel temporaire de
loloyer. Ça, ça coûte pas un sel
sosou à l'État québécois. En
cece moment, les loyers exploset
papartout au Québec.
- - Et tous les coûts explosent
auaussi, hein. C'est l'inflation
ququi explose.
- - Exact. Mais la question,
c c'est sur quoi le gouvernemet
pepeut agir?
- - Oui.
- - On ne nationalisera pas
lele steak haché, on n'imposera
papas un prix plafond sur
lele Kraft Dinner. Il y a des
chchoses que le gouvernement ne
pepeut pas contrôler. Donc,
ilil faut se concentrer sur ce e
l'l'État québécois peut contrôl.
LeLes loyers, ça en fait partie.
OnOn pourrait mieux réglementer
leles loyers au Québec pour évir
leles hausses abusives et
s's'assurer que les gens ne
dodonnent pas 25, 30, 40, 50 % e
leleurs revenunus chaque mois à
leleur logement. C'est beaucoup
trtrop et ça appauvrit, pas
seseulement les gens les plus
dédémunis, ça appauvrit même
dodorénavant la classe moyenne u
QuQuébec, des prix des logements
ququi augmentent aussi rapideme.
- - Très bien. Madame Massé
paparlait à vos côtés, je pense
hihier, elle disait : "On parle
bebeaucoup de fierté, mais pas e
lala crise du logement." Et tout
çaça. Est-ce qu'il y a un piègeà
dededans?
- - Moi, je pense que ce qui
dedevrait nous rendre fiers au
QuQuébec, c'est un Québec de
jujustice sociale. Un Québec où
onon diminue l'écart entre
leles riches et les pauvres.
- - D'accord.
- - Un Québec où des gens qui
trtravaillent à temps plein ne
fofont pas la file dans
leles banques alimentaires pour
s's'alimenter. Moi, ça,
çaça me rendrait fier de vivre
dadans un Québec comme ça. Puis
c'c'est ça, le Québec qu'on esse
dede construire, toute l'équipee
QuQuébec solidaire.
- - Merci Gabriel Nadeau-Dubois.
- - Merci Madame Dussaul